this is how some Europeans want to
convince British people to stay in the
you by spreading the love and giving big
hugs
a group of experts here in Britain have
come up with the campaign hugger Brits
they say it's their love bomb or Britain
we have about positive emotions about
the relationship between Brits and
Europeans and I think we really made an
impact on changing the emotions around
it and bring a positive touch to the
campaign
a lot of people who were positive and we
want to stay in or who are undecided if
they see these sentiments and that there
are a lot of Europeans who care and to
want a strong UK in the unit who we want
the bridge to Cheney you for better
Europe I think there a lot of kids who
care about it
you know that the unity is strength
while you are divided you don't have to
spend any more ignorant should get out
and why because we have english-speaking
nations that we can trade with we don't
need Europe for trade so I think we're
just going to be better off independent
and sail around boat but if Europeans
would hug you would that convince you to
maybe stay I always liked being hugged
by Europeans so are you staying now I'll
think about it